this missile launch happened just before
g20 summit in Germany where President
Trump meets with other world leaders
they include the presidents of China
South Korea and Russia mr. Trump
returned to Washington last night after
a weekend trip to New Jersey Golf Club
Kris Van Cleave is in Washington Chris
good morning good morning the president
was briefed late last night on North
Korea's latest ballistic missile launch
just a day earlier President Trump spoke
with Chinese President Xi Jinping about
containing North Korea's nuclear weapons
program according to the New York Times
president Trump told the Chinese
president the United States is prepared
to act on its own in dealing with North
Korea but the White House's official
statement on the call said the two
leaders reaffirmed their commitment to a
denuclearized Korean Peninsula the once
warm relationship between between the
two presidents has chilled as North
Korea continues its push for nuclear
weapons
yesterday Russian President Vladimir
Putin hosted President Xi in Moscow
Putin is set to meet with President
Trump for the first time on Friday it is
still unclear if President Trump will
address Russian meddling in the u.s.
election or continued sanctions on
Russia
yesterday the Kremlin said it's patience
with the u.s. is running out Jeff Chris
thank you very much